[Müzik]
Merhabalar
Ben Sarp Bozkurt
kafasının içinde
sürekli Sezen Aksu'nun kutlama şarkısı
çalan
memleketi de çoktan Bahar Gelmiş ama
bunu geç farketmiş biri olarak
karşınızda bulunuyorum
Ben her şeyi erteleyen biriydim
hayatım boyunca böyle oldu
Eskiden yaşamayı Sadece vakit geçirmek
için
yaşayan biriyken şimdi
yaşama tutkusuyla dolup taşan bir insan
haline geldim Eskiden
o zamanlar yani
olmak istediğim adamdan her geçen gün
biraz daha uzaklaşıyordum ama şimdi
olduğum adamla Her gün biraz daha fazla
gurur duyuyorum işte size Bunun
hikayesini anlatacağım bunu anlatmak
için yaşadığım evreleri dörde böldüm
bir
ertelememek iki kabul etmek 3
yargılamamak
4 mutlu olmayı seçmek ve şükretmek bu
Aslında her yerde gördüğünüz çok
alışılageldik başlıkları yaşamanın
gerçekten imkansız olmadığının canlı bir
kanıtı olarak karşınızda bulunuyorum
aynı zamanda mühendisin O yüzden size
bunları rasyonel bir şekilde anlatmak
için Bu maddelerin arasını ama ve bu
yüzdenlerle dolduracağım
şimdi bu Hikayemiz 2018 yılından önce
dayanıyor
o zamanlar
bahsettiğim gibi her şeyi erteleyen
biriydim ama her şeyi
çalışmayı dinlenmeyi mutlu olmayı mutsuz
olmayı olan güzel bir şeyle gülmeyi
ağlamayı
duygularımı yaşamayı her şeyi
erteliyordum erteliyormuşum daha doğrusu
Çünkü insan yaşarken Bunun farkına
varmıyor Tabii ki
duygularımı yaşamayı da ertelediğimi
fark etmem acı bir tecrübeye dayanıyor
1 Nisan 2016'da babamı kaybettim çok
güçlü durmuştum
hiç ağlamıyordum güçlü durmak için çaba
sarf etmiyordum ama baya güçlüydüm ve 2
yıl böyle yaşadım sonra o sabah
29 Kasım 2018 Sabahı
havlayarak uyandım
Ama böyle nasıl bir Ağlama yani bayağı
içimden parçalar gidiyor
çok da mantıklı bir sebebi var ağlamamın
Babamı özlemiştim yani
onunla yeterince vakit geçirmediğimi onu
bazen üzdüğümü
onunla bir daha müzik dinleyemeyeceğimi
ki yapmaya En sevdiğimiz aktiviteydi
birlikte dans edemeyeceğimizi falan
düşünüyordum ve bunlarda çok haklıydım
Çünkü hayat böyle bir şey yaşamak için
tek bir şansınız var
ve tahmin edebileceğiniz üzere bu Ağlama
seansı
bir sürü Keşkelerle doluydu
Keşke çok karanlık bir yer Ama iki
taraflı çalışan bir mekanizma Yani hem
yaptıklarınız hem de yapmadıklarınız
için Keşke diyebilirsiniz İşte o
hayatımı değiştiren Ağlama seansının
sonunda Evet ya dedim ben bundan sonra
yaptıklarım için Keşke demeyi seçiyorum
dedim ben bundan sonra istediğimi ve
hissettiğimi yaşayacağım dedim
söylemesi inanılmaz kolayda bir cümle bu
Bunu ben bundan sonra istediğimi ve
hissettiğimi yaşayacağım diyen bir sürü
insan var ama
karşılarına yaşamak zorunda oldukları
bir şey çıktığı anda
istediğini değil yapmak zorunda olduğu
şeyi yapıyor çoğu insan
Neyse ben bu kararımı biraz böyle
gerçekten doğru bir karar mı verdim
falan bunu bir ölçüp biçmek için biraz
da bu Ağlama seansının
Bendeki bu hüznünü azaltmak için
sokağa Attım kendimi eşimle birlikte
böyle normal yürüyoruz
sonra
her yürürken her kırmızı ışığa
geldiğimizde o kırmızı ışık yeşile döndü
belki 3 kere oldu ama bana 33 kere geldi
Çünkü ben bunu öyle yorumlamak
istemiştim o anda Bu bakış açısına
ihtiyacım varmış hayatımda sonra eşime
döndüm dedim ki
bak Aşkım aşkım diyordum o vakitler
aşkım
bundan sonra bütün hayatım böyle gidecek
Ben gitmek istediğim yere gideceğim ve
önümdeki bütün kırmızı ışıklar yeşile
dönecek dedi
Ama tabii ki hayatımın böyle bir akış
içinde ilerlemesini sağlamak için
hiçbir şeyi ertelemem gerekiyordu
şimdi ilk başta bahsettiğim rasyonel
olma kısmına geliyorum
hiçbir şeyi ertelememek için o anda
istediğim ve hissettiğim şeyi yapmam
gerekiyordu ama bunların bir sonuçları
olacaktı Bu yüzden bu sonuçları kabul
etmem gerekiyordu
şimdi
Hayatınız boyunca
önünüze istediğinizi ve hissettiğinizi
yapmanız için sizi yüreklendiren bir
sürü slogan çıktı
Carpe diem
anı yaşa
Hayat bir gün o da bugün öyle şeyler bu
bir sürü insanın Dövmesi olan bu sözleri
Yaşamak aslında bunları okumak kadar
kolay değil gerçekten zor ve bunlar için
Bedel ödemeniz gerekiyor
çünkü
her şeyinin ve yaptığın her seçimin
mutlaka bir sonucu var ve bu sonuçları
kabul etmen gerekiyor
mesela kabul etmek ne demek
Bu arada kabul etmek benim bu
Mutluluğa giden yoldaki tırnak içinde
aşmam gereken en zor adımdı
nedir kabul etmek
her şeyi kabul etmek yani
birini üzdüğünü sevdiklerini hayal
kırıklığına uğrattığını
kendinden ve yeteneğinden emin olmadığın
için özgüvensiz olduğunu ve bu
özgüvensizliğin acısını başkalarını
kırarak çıkardığını
insanları seni sevenleri hayal
kırıklığına uğrattığını Bunları kabul
etmek ve bunları sayınca sen acaba kötü
bir insan mısın yani iyi şeyler saymadın
diye olabilirsiniz ama ben sadece dürüst
bir insanım Çünkü bu saydıklarım
Her insanın yaptığı şeyler Aslında ve
eğer istediğinizi ve hissettiğinizi
yapıyorsanız mutlaka Bunları kabul
etmeniz gereken sonuçlar ortaya
çıkacaktır emin olun bundan
size bu kabul etme
olayını bir tane böyle Somut bir örnekle
bizzat yaşadığım Somut bir örnekle
anlatacağım
Ben senaryo yazmaya ve hikaye
oluşturmaya Sevdalı bir insanım
mesleğimdi bu
hayattaki en büyük tutkum da bu Ama
bunun için sabahlara kadar ofiste
çalışmamız gerekiyor bazen
sabaha kadar ofiste çalışıyorum
yorgun bir şekilde sabah eve gidiyorum
kapıyı açtığımda çoktan
uyanmış çoktan kahvaltısını etmiş çoktan
birlikte vakit geçirmiş
hayal kırıklığıyla
ve yalnız gözlerle bana bakan eşim ve 1
yaşındaki çocuğumun gözünün içine bakmam
gerekiyordu
şimdi
Hiçbirimiz Tabii ki ailemize hayal
kırıklığına uğratmak istemeyiz Hatta
çoğumuz bunu kaldıramayız da
Bu yüzden
istediğini ve hissettiğini yapmak o
Havalı cümlelerdeki gibi bir şey değil
gerçekten Bedel ödemen gerekiyor Peki
ben bunu yaptığım için mutsuz muyum çok
net Hayır
değilim çünkü
ben yine bunun sonucunu kabul ediyorum
kabul ettim
ve
ileride
bu hayatta en çok istediğim şey için
yeterince çabalamadığımı fark edip bu
mutsuzlukla bütün
yakınımdakileri suçlamak yerine bu
bedeli ödemeyi tercih ettim
peki
başka çirkin bir soru bu beni kötü bir
babaya yapar mı
bilmiyorum
şimdi Elbette burada bu verdiğim örnek
kötü bir örnekti yani Hayatımda Tabii ki
bir denge kurmaya çalışıyorum bazen
başarılı oluyorum bazen başarısız
oluyorum bu kötü bir örnekti bütün
hayatım sürekli ofiste ve ailem 1 saat
görüp Sonra ofise gitmekle geçmiyor
tabii ki ama
hata yaptım
hata yapıyorum ve Hata yapacağım ve
bunların hepsinde kabul ediyorum
İşte bu derece
her şeyi kabul etmek
insan hayatında başka bir kapı Daha
açıyor Özgüven kapısı
başarılı veya başarısızlığını Kabul
ettiğinde
özgüvenli bir insan haline geliyorsun
ve özgüvenli bir insana kim ne zarar
verebilir ki zaten kim olduğunu ve
yaptığın bütün hareketlerin ve bütün
seçimlerin bir sonucu olacağını kabul
ediyorsun ve bu
yargılamamaya götürüyor seni
daha doğrusu
yargılamamaktan önce
yargılanmayı da kabul ediyorsun çünkü
çünkü mutlu olmayı seçtin yöntemden
dolayı biliyorsun ki birileri seni
yargılayacak mutlaka
sen de aynısını yaptığın için kimseyi
yargılamamaya başlıyorsun Çünkü Kimin
nasıl bir hayat yaşadığını bilemezsin ve
birilerinin aldığı kararlar
ve bu kararların doğruluğu veya
yanlışlığı Seninle alakalı şeyler değil
ki zaten doğru veya yanlış diye bir şey
de yok bu insana göre veya insanın bakış
açısına göre değişen bir şey
ve bu
yargılamamayı öğrenmek
insanı çok rahatlatan bir şey hayatın
yargıladığın şeyi sana yaşatmak gibi
harika bir huyu var mükemmel bir şey
yani az önce anlattığım olayda
böyle içten içe
yapanların ailelerini hayal kırıklığına
uğratacağına yemin edebilirim
Çünkü hepimiz insanız ve herkes
Hayatında en az bir kere ailesini hayal
kırıklığına uğratacak maalesef
ben
mutlu olmanın bir seçim olduğuna
inanıyorum
ve yaşadığım her olayda da beni mutlu
edecek şükredecek bir şey bulmaya
çalışıyorum Şu zamana kadar da
her zaman buldum eğer Zaten mutsuz olmak
istersen en ufak olayda da seni mutsuz
edecek bir şey bulabilirsin O yüzden
mutlu olmanın bir seçimi olduğuna
inanıyorum
sözlerimi de
Neredesin Firuze adlı Filmdeki bir
replikle bitireceğim
intihar etmek istiyorsanız yaşayarak
edin Çok teşekkürler
[Alkış]
[Müzik]